well going to the movies on christmas is
a real tradition for so many of us
and even during the pandemic some were
able to keep that ritual going
wonder woman 1984 premiering today in
theaters
also on hbo max this is the first movie
on the water brothers roster to be
released simultaneously both in theaters
and online it all matter to me it's all
the same but i love the smell of popcorn
so
come out here to movie theater i agree
with that warner brothers will release
17 movies next year
both online and in theaters and if
you're worried about going to the movies
during the pandemic
many theaters are actually offering
private showings
for small groups so bianca i have not
seen
any of the wonder woman franchise
unfortunately but i'm curious what's
your favorite christmas movie on this
christmas day
um my favorite christmas movie i have
two so i like
the grinch the cartoon version okay and
then i also like
the preacher's wife with denzel
washington and whitney houston yeah i uh
i'll uh yours what's yours well i'll
fully admit that today
uh before coming into work today i was
sitting on my couch
uh watching love actually sobbing to
myself
such a great movie